this is a production of Cornell
University actually one of the things I
did in this presentation was tried to
remove most of the math there was a lot
of math in there so I produced a lot of
that and hopefully made it digestible
okay so yeah as John Luke introduced I
did my masters at New Mexico State
University I was working on auto
tetraploid alfalfa there and
particularly in transpiration efficiency
these are leaf peels just for fun you
can see the little stomata there and why
I got when I came or now I got
interested in G by E because I had seen
it right so so a little a little
exciting when I get in there so you can
see here this this is a this was a study
I had during my Master's it's under
really heavy drought conditions and
you'll notice the alfalfa that's going
right in front of it is much healthier
so there are differential responses to
environment and so I'm gonna briefly
talk about a little bit of the work I've
done with genotype and by environment
interaction mostly just as a plug or a
our package I wrote and then I'm gonna
move on to the part of my PhD that I'm
most excited about okay
so typically we think of genotype by or
typically we think of a phenotype as
some function of the genetics and the
environment in which those plants are in
however you know different genotypes
respond differently to different
environments and so there's really an
interaction term here this this is GE
right so there's some population mean mu
some genetic effects some environmental
effect and then some deviation from that
from that additive model okay and
so I was interested in utilizing
utilizing what's called an additive main
effects multiplicative interaction
popularized by Hugh Gao himself and
who's sitting in the audience which is
great to have him here so he can put me
out on all the things I've been wrong so
anyway the idea is is that you can think
of you can think of this problem as a
matrix right you have a table of
genotypes in some environments right so
here I've got a table of genotypes where
they're the same across all environments
and a table of environment effects where
they're the same across all genotypes
and then I have some deviation from that
ok and but so the problem with with this
G by E term is what we'd like to do you
typically want to separate out the
largest sources of variability as the
treat you know the Chronicle true G by E
and pull out the smaller sources is
error and this is particularly useful
when you have unreplicated field trials
okay so this is done through right so
this is a matrix right and what we can
do is use singular value decomposition
to find linear combinations of that G by
E matrix that are the most associated
with that G by E effect okay or explain
the bulk of the variance now estimating
how many of these we should pull out
right so we're trying to find K of them
is is another problem especially for
unreplicated data because the the G by E
effect and the error okay so I developed
a an r package called bilinear that fits
a me models it also fits other bilinear
models such as the GG e and the g reg i
don't know some of you may be familiar
with these I'm not going to talk about
them in great detail there's quite a bit
of literature on this I my my preferred
method is the a me because I think it's
most parsimonious
and so this this this package that I
wrote fits various models and can't you
know does some you know produces plots
and tests but more importantly has a
couple of tests for how many of these
dimensions we should pull out of the G
by a turn in particular we have an F our
test that was developed by P fo and 95
and this is great for replicated data or
at least data where you have a known
within trial variance but when we don't
have replicated data we can use a
parametric bootstrap method that was
developed by fork min and P so I've
implemented these in this our package
because at the time there were no are
packages that would fit these and I
think that now there's a gge at GUI or
something like that it's a it's a
graphic user interface but it is in our
but this this this fits both types of
models and and it tests and what's
really important is is that this can
handle unreplicated data now the test
tends to be more conservative than the
apart but it's really useful especially
for our trials where we don't
necessarily have replication looking
environment because there's been this
big shift to moving toward putting much
more lines in a trial as opposed to
replicating those lines many many times
within a trial okay and so this is
available on github I'm still uncertain
it probably needs a little bit more
polishing before it'll ever go on to
cram and but right now from github you
can install this directly in our using
the package so that's kind of fun so
these are just some examples for those
of you not familiar with a bi plot
essentially what you're doing is you're
you decompose this thing right and
you're looking at there's a genotype
dimension and an environment dimension
so we have the first two principal
components of the genotype and the first
two principal components related to the
environment okay and so I'm not going to
go into the details of how to interpret
these models in particular but basically
these by class are useful because
relationships between
environments or genotypes and genotypes
and environments are related by their
angles okay where where a cue angles are
associated with positive relationships
and right angles are associated with
independence and a negative relationship
right so so Helfer here help for 2014
here is a very different environment
from say khatola 16 but apparently has a
very independent G by E response whereas
these sets of environments are all
relatively in the G by E response okay
and then we can do things like we can
make these these winter plots that are
also out of Gaussian so veld 97 I
believe and what you what we do here is
we we have the main effect of the
genotype and then the slope is the a
me--one fit right that says how they
respond to a changing environment so
down here we've ranked the environments
and indicated them with these look like
triangles and then you can see that
there are individuals that do
particularly good in poor environments
and then their response goes down as the
environment decreases whereas their
individuals that do particularly well in
good environments but not particularly
bad environments okay so this was just
to kind of introduce this package we've
I've worked together with Lisa
kissing Cusack a colleague of mine in
Mars lab she was looking at organic
wheat yield trials that were replicated
from Vermont and North Dakota looking at
the response of organic grains to
different growing environments and she
found that there was significant
location or genotype by location effects
such that it made sense to have these
decentralized programs in these
different region now this this study was
nice because it was replicated but we
ended up using the parametric bootstrap
regardless because they tended to give
more biological relevant numbers of
interactions so typically fewer
dimensions
right so KK was low like 1 or 2 that's
in contrast to another paper I worked on
with another student from Mark's lad
Lundeen straw both of these students
have graduated this one hasn't quite
been submitted yet but it's very close
and we worked on G by E and we were able
to show that there were significant G by
E effects but in general the genetic
correlation across the environments that
she evaluated in New York were very
similar or was was relatively high so
then we were able to recommend that that
breeding for fruit and content could be
done with relatively few environments if
only a single environment and as well as
under a genomic selection scape now this
one we did not have replicated
individuals so this in this case the
parametric bootstrap was really
convenient to have ok now I'm gonna move
on to Ella polyploid really what I want
to talk about so in my second year of
grad school I was taking a course with
marks laurels that I think many of you
have taken it's basically a paper review
class and in that class we read this
paper by James McKee that was published
about in 1970s almost 50 years ago and
he talks about how there okay so he
notes that that whole genome duplication
events are just pervasive in the blankey
they're everywhere especially in
angiosperms right where even if you know
there are these paleo polyploid events
that happened a long time ago and then
there's a bunch that have happened
relatively recently too and he talks
about how there's this balance and be in
in creating new genetic variation but
then preserving particularly good sets
of alleles right and so so one thing he
notes is that a low polyploids have this
ability to establish homozygosity so
that they can keep good sets of alleles
but they end up being heterozygous
across the sub genomes now that might
sound a little confusing and I'm going
to clarify in a second and that
essentially this idea of a low
polyploidy bringing bringing
relatively you know closely related
species together into the same organism
allowed for multitudes of gene functions
that should allow for broader out
adaptation or you know adaptation a much
broader landscape because you have these
different combinations of alleles to
draw from for different genetic pathways
okay so a little a little on bread wheat
so there was the a genome ancestor and B
genome ancestor the a genome ancestor
you may know today as einkorn start the
same species is very closely related and
the B genome species is thought to be
extinct and which is unfortunate I wish
I hope that one day we find it and you
know roughly half a million years ago
there was a spontaneous cross between
these two closely related species and
they produced a tetraploid that had that
had both an A and a B genome right so
all this one you took a complete set of
genes from one species and a complete
set from another and you brought them in
the same organism all right and then
this happened again
roughly ten thousand years ago and maybe
only once with a related species called
a jalops how GI which contributed the G
excuse me of a D genome to common wheat
okay so now what we know of is common
wheat which you know bread we primarily
bread wheat but of course also wheat for
cake flour and so on and so forth has
three separate genomes ie three sets
complete sets of genes okay and I've
just been fascinated why what is the
driving mechanism for duplicating an
entire genome right so so a single gene
we imagine may get duplicated and then
you you can maintain function with one
copy and allow the other one to diverge
but what what is the what is the
advantage of having complete whole set
or you know of genes okay and so so so
here's kind of lay this out right we
have three genomes in a low hexaploid
wheat and undergoes disomic inheritance
which means there's no crossing over
between homologous chromosomes so more
or less the three sets maintain
themselves within
they don't they don't switch pieces it's
self pollinated so it can fix itself
right so so so it becomes completely in
bread and and individuals will self
pollinate and produce seed that is
genetically identical to the parent
right so they this is the self
preserving part but they maintain this
allelic diversity across the three
genome okay so this is the this is the
you know the new generating part right
so you grab you grab a whole set of
genes from from one species and one from
the other station I got two sets of
tools right and so I'm wondering is we
can we think of wheat as an immortalized
hybrid okay so you brought two okay and
so here's my here's my justification for
this okay so in typical hybrid
generation you've some sets of alleles
XY and Z that are in an open pollinated
population they get separated from one
another either intentionally or
unintentionally into two hetero duck
groups Group A and Group B and then when
you bring these back together to form
the hybrid you've essentially
established hetero zygosity at all those
I and you know you have these allelic
interaction which we believe may be
important for for what we observe as
hybrid bigger which is the which is
essentially the tendency for offspring
to be better than their than their
parents okay
so now think about the Ella polyploid
right we have some set of alleles in the
in the in the common ancestor and then
these are a lot you know these may
diverge in the in the descendant species
uses a and B and then you bring them
back together but again right so so this
thing becomes inbred and what you've
done is essentially established hetero
zygosity although sign but now you fix
this hetero zygosity because it you
through selfing right and the this
disomic inheritance so so what I'm
curious about is can we see evidence of
homie allelic interactions that are you
know analogous to allelic interactions
that we see in traditional diploid
hybrids okay and so to investigate this
I wanted to know how this played out on
agronomic traits now we have a winter
wheat breeding population here at
Cornell and so I kind of curated this
data set it's roughly 9,000 phenotypic
records 1,500 lines crossed about ten
years two to three environments per year
and and we have evaluated them for
portraits essentially in every year now
this is a lot of work
it's funny how this amount of man-hours
can be you know distilled down into
9,000 you know lines on a you know a
computer file somewhere
and I will definitely recognize people
who have helped put this together okay
so this is the data I'm going to be
working with to describe this
investigation to you so first thing I
was interested in is sub genome additive
and interaction effects we typically
think okay so coming back to this idea
we typically think of the phenotype as
some you know summation of all the
genetic effects okay on average but
there's no reason why we can't split
these into their individual sub genome
effects okay and we can estimate these
using you know a very standard genomic
prediction model where and I don't you
know ignore the math math is not
particularly important it's just to say
that here we're getting a single
estimate for a breeding you know for the
for the value of every individual based
on its entire genome whereas for
for in this model we get a different
estimate for each individual based on
the free sub genome so you get three
estimates right one for a one cookie one
for D ok and we what this is very simple
to do we estimate the covariance between
individuals using molecular markers and
so we can subset those markers based on
their native genome and then we can
calculate the the covariance between
individuals based on each separate
genome
ok for all three and and here's a
motivating example to think of why we
might be interested in this imagine we
had this little toy population of three
individuals and we want to pick two to
me the obvious choice might be
individuals one and two which have the
highest two values but then if we could
see you know for their whole genome but
if we could see their individual effects
for their sub genomes um well note that
they while they both have very good AMV
genomes they don't tend to have a very
good DG so when we make these guys the
best value we could possibly obtain is
12 right whereas whereas you know
contradictory if you included the third
individual with the lowest breeding
value right you have this potential to
bring it well it doesn't do very good on
a and P it does have and you increase
the the you know the maximum value from
that cross okay and similarly a you know
this is true for both of the two process
with it okay so and and more importantly
potentially we
look at individuals that have the exact
same breeding value and find ones that
might have particularly good sub genomes
that we want to incorporate for specific
crosses and so what I've done here is
I've I've I've plotted the the breeding
values or the or the you know the value
that we assigned to the individual based
on its whole genome or the sub genome
effect a B&B right and then and then and
then I've highlighted kind of the best
5% of the individuals here and what I
want I just want to point out briefly
you know the the individual that has the
best a genome here is not the individual
with the best whole genome nor does it
have a particularly good B genome it's
very moderate and similarly the best B
genome individual right has a moderate a
and so these are these blue blue squares
and and you know the best you know best
individual for the D genome again has a
you know relatively moderate values for
the amv so you might say okay well let's
let's take you know the individuals best
for a and made it to the one that's the
best ability you know and similarly so
in this case for grain yield you know
maybe most of these individuals or at
least be in your pool of individuals you
might select to do this even if you
wouldn't necessarily make these crosses
but you can see for test weight for
example the best D individual it doesn't
have a particularly good whole genome
with that so it might be thrown out
altogether and never considered for
population so so what this allows us to
do is it allows us to select on
complimentary sub genomes for crossing
right we can bring ones that have
different you know good effects together
now you could do this with any set of
chromatin right you could estimate a
breeding value for every chromosome if
you want but that's this gets more
complicated the more of these you have
interestingly the other thing we could
do is increase in is select on sub
genomes specifically right like so one
of the problems is you'll notice the D
genome has significantly less variance
than the amb which means that when you
make selections based on phenotypes you
are making selections on the largest
sources of variants which are coming
from the AMD
so a lot of this work you know a lot of
the variation in the D genome is going
to get fixed just through drift and so
you could you could select base just on
them eating for example for several
rounds you know after say introgression
inter dressing from a wild species or
something like that but this is just
those were just individual sub genome X
right what I really care about is how
are these things interacting with one
another and we do this through using how
to market products of these covariances
the math isn't really important it's
just it's just that we can now get a
value for every individual based on its
interaction between a and B genome B and
D and the amp and the and D alright and
then we can estimate these variants
components and here what I've shown is
the different terms
a BD a by B a by D for a couple of
traits the the estimates are in red with
their standard deviations and then the
violin thoughts are our distributions
from sampling that data so we subset the
data we estimate those variance
components actually during
cross-validation but what we can do is
just see how stable is that variance
estimate will notice it for the most
part they align very well with their
estimates interestingly you'll notice
there's very different genetic
architecture between these two traits
while the B genome explains you know
most of the variants in both of them
you'll notice that here the the D genome
explains a lot more for plant height
than it does for granule and the a by D
and B by D interaction effects are much
larger than than they are in granule
where they're actually very small so so
granule doesn't have a whole lot going
on or sub G no interactions but we do
see it from play and then we can show
that these things some to two to the
same variants as the full genetic effect
as well as their interactions okay we
can incorporate these interactions into
a genomic prediction model and we can
see that when we model just the additive
effects of the whole genome versus the
three individuals and then some of them
you'll see that we get essentially the
exact same prediction accuracy for all
trades and and then if we incorporate
epistatic interactions one of the things
we can do is incorporate all
interactions or we can just incorporate
the interactions across the saloons
we'll notice that again
you see what we see increases in
prediction accuracy for all the traits
except for arguably grain yield here and
that those increases are the same
regardless of whether or not we're
modeling all pairwise or or just the
pairwise across sub jeans however the
problem is is that these things are not
independent right so so you know you
know in a population under pure
hardy-weinberg these these variance
components should be independent of each
other but we do have population
structure it's not like we see in
something like rice for example but you
know this is this is just a PC plot of
the genetic covariance and you know
where we're explaining maybe you know
eighteen percent or so of the of the
variance which is the first two
principal components so there is some
population structure in here and it's
Mason basically it probably mostly due
to the fact that with many small
families right so this is done you know
wheat is done a pedigree selection so
this is not some big random mating you
know population of cattle right there
are very specific crosses there are few
individuals from each cross that go into
it you know advance trial so there could
be confounding of estimates here and so
I had an attempt to try to remove the
largest sources of variation from the
marker matrix before we actually
calculate how related individuals are so
basically under hardy-weinberg these
variances should be independent but
typically in a breeding program they
will not be so we can take the marker
matrix and decompose it using singular
value decomposition which is obviously
my favorite tool because that's what we
used for the ami model and we can pull
out the first few principal components
as populations
I'm calling that Q we can reform the
marker matrix after we pulled that
population out of all of the markers at
the same time and we reform this by
setting the the the first case singular
values of D to 0 and and multiplying
right so we make this D tilde multiply
isn't important again but then then we
just incorporate our population
structure as a fixed effect and then we
have the sum of our different sub genome
of okay so now I can pull out this this
M and make a covariance from that so and
so forth and while having removed
population structure from all three of
them at the same time okay
when we do that okay so what I've done
here is I've plotted in the black lines
here showing the correlation of genetic
relationships estimated based on the a
genome and the D genome or the a genome
and the B genome and or the B genome of
the genome and you'll notice that they
tend to have a high correlation right
and that's because individuals that are
closely related are going to be closely
related to each other no matter which
pieces of DNA you choose to calculate
that relationship but also because of
population structure and it looks like
we have this nice shelf here right so
you know roughly around a K of maybe
four or five it looks like we kind of
hit this asymptotic relationship where
where where the more principal
components we pull out of that market
matrix we don't get much reduction in
the correlation of the relationships
across the subject okay we also take a
hit in the amount of variance in the
entire population or in the entire
matrix so we can so what I've done is
okay so we know we know that K appears
to be removing right so pulling out this
population structure appears to be
removing these various opponents but
through as as I increase K to I see big
you know changes and you'll notice for
the a B and the D genomes no matter what
the size of K for these four traits the
the additive values don't differ very
much but their interaction components do
have rank changes especially for these
different
four traits that are not very old
so it's really unclear whether or not
we're pulling population structure out
or also genetic signal right because
they're related to each other what I did
was I used the variance of the variance
estimates to decide whether or not we
should be doing this and in general
there is not much change in this
covariance okay so the variance
components related to the interactions
and have a high correlation regardless
of how much population structure you a
lot of this thing so in general this was
probably not there probably isn't a
whole lot of benefit to this or if there
is it's really unclear at least in this
population may be very important for
certain populations that have very
strict sets of population structure like
in rice for example but of course that's
a diploid okay so we estimated the
additive effects relatively well it's
not certain if we get good interactions
we don't lose prediction accuracy so
there's no reason not to do this from a
predictive perspective but it's unclear
how you would then make selections on
each individual right we can we can do
complimentary sub genome selection we
select individuals that particularly
good versus individuals have
particularly good B's we can select
certain sub genomes and what's great
about this method is we don't need to
know much about where the marker lives
only what genome it came from which is
important in crops like wheat where for
a long time we knew where markers
belonged from a perspective of what
chromosome they are they were on but had
no idea what the what their relative
position next one another was because
each of the chromosome arms was
assembled independently yes and this is
true for a lot of polyploid sequence
assembly is very difficult because you
have the right because it's replicated
it's like you're trying to sequence
three different things at the same time
so it's hard to assign from those way
okay so this paper
preparation is really close I'm hoping
we're gonna get this one out soon but I
want to talk about explicitly modeling
homie ologists relationships we can
consider a 2 locus model right where we
have a locus B say on one genome and a
locus see on another genome with
additive effects alpha B alpha C and
their interaction ok and so there's
different ways to think about how
epistasis works there's a classic
additive by additive I'm not gonna go
into this too much this is this is what
you get from multiplying marker scores
and anyone who's done this is probably
seeing this relationship your
contrasting you know the two homozygotes
little weird thing to say because
remember they're all as I guess from the
heterozygotes across the genomes right
you can look at the duplicate factor
model where essentially having a B or a
C gives you the effect and having both
of them does not give you any further
effect right so if this coefficient was
2 it would be completely additive but
it's it's it's only that it's the same
as having one or the other and I'm going
to introduce this idea of sub
functionalisation epistasis and this is
actually a pretty so this model is
flexible it allows both everything from
a duplicate factor all the way to an
additive and then beyond and so I'm
gonna go into this I'm going to give you
an example of this so you have some
ancestor allele a and it it is allowed
to change into the two descendant
species and when that's brought back
together in the allo polyploid you
essentially get the sum of those two
effects times some divergence
coefficient right where you can see that
if d equals one this is completely
additive if d equals half it's
completely redundant and if it's
somewhere in between a half and one it
there's there's some partial redundancy
okay and when I say partial redundancy I
mean I mean these genes still to some
extent perform similar functions such a
having one or the other doesn't result
in a total loss of function but but you
need both of them to have complete
functionality in
in the organism okay so this is your
classic epistasis plot where you have
you know a change from C to Big C you
know little C the Big C change from
little bita Big B
I'm gonna explain this using an example
so we had a by parental population that
was that where the two parents each had
a single dwarfing gene you know the
dwarf in genes from that were very
famous from the Green Revolution
essentially if you have one of these
dwarfing genes you're what you are
what's called a semi dwarf that brings
the height of the plant down such that
when you put a bunch of fertilizer on it
it doesn't all over which is called
lodging and when obviously the plants
all over and they lodge we are you know
all total grain loss so making these
guys short is good but you don't want to
make them too short okay
so what's interesting is this population
had one parent had a dwarfing gene on
the B genome the other one had a
dwarfing gene on the DG no this RHD one
okay now because we made this cross
there are double dwarfs in this
population so they have two mutant genes
that are completely different and
sensitive and they are tiny
they're super short and here we've
tagged them with markers that were
relatively close you notice it's not
perfect
but when we look at the mean of the
population of the double dwarf and then
we can look at the effect of adding a
wild type D allele there's a linear
response similarly there's a linear
response when we add a wild type B
allele to the double dwarf and now based
on additive 'ti you would expect the
mean of the the double roughly here but
when we observe this it is significantly
lower than you might expect
okay so there's this deviation from the
additive model right
classic episode change the slope okay
and so this this value Delta is how what
you know we can estimate this directly
and we can calculate this divergence
coefficient D okay and then essentially
you know this is this great example of
one plus one does not equal two there is
some functional redundancy between these
two genes now this
different from their being pure
redundancy in which case you would see
this right where this Delta is is
exactly you know where this this slip is
now flat so one or the other gives you
the you know the wild type and this is
obviously different from seeing an
increase in response okay so that's one
gene but I wanted to know do I see this
pattern across the genome okay
and so using the the international wheat
genome sequencing consortium refseq one
I was that with roughly 1100 coding
sequences I was able to basically
establish homeo allelic gene sets
roughly 18,000 triplicates 5000 doubles
so triplets means one on a when I'm b1
on D the expected places and then the
duplicates is one on a and one on B but
you're missing one on safety right so we
end up with about 23,000 homie ologist
sets and then I tagged those sets with
GPS markers so now I can track them okay
and I ended up with a total of about
10,000 markers now when we look at so
what what can we do we can take these we
can take these molecular markers and we
can do G walks right which is our
favorite thing to do here and what I've
done is I've plotted the the 21
chromosomes of wheat around the circle
and then I'm indicated these are like
Manhattan plots here so these are the
negative log 10 of the p-values and
you'll see we don't have a bunch of huge
hits there's a couple plant height we
have the dwarfing gene on 4d heading
date we have PPD 1 on 2d for example but
there's not a whole lot of large Becky
TL however you notice from earlier we
had a high prediction accuracy with BC
so there is genetic signal in there it's
just going to be that just indicates
that where there's many genes we're
looking at that are involved in this
similarly we don't find a whole lot of
quote-unquote significant homie ologist
HEPA static interactions and these are
indicated by these hoops here so you
know a couple on three couple on four up
on five couple on seven relatively few
however
um we can look at the global trend of
these individuals or of these low sigh
okay so so and then and then we can see
do they increase prediction actually I'm
gonna get to that in a couple of slides
what I've done here is I've plotted oh
my gosh I'm running low on time so what
I've done is I've plotted the home of
like one homolog say the a genome home
you log effect against the other homeo
log which is the like say the B okay and
then and then in color I've indicated
the direction of the interaction of
their inner their pairwise interaction
and their magnitude is is shown with the
size of the of the point here and you'll
notice that we see this drastic negative
trend between the additive effects and
their interaction right so if you have a
positive if if both of your both of your
alleles are positive your interaction
tends to be negative and vice versa
okay and so I was like yeah this is
totally showing me exactly what I
thought this is this is sub
functionalization right but this has to
do with how we coded this so what we
were doing is we were contrasting
genotypes you're trying to assign who
has you know what is the functional copy
and and this is using you know zero one
marker coding and what happens is if so
so to check to make sure I'm not crazy I
simulated a data set using the exact
same parameters from the original four
data sets using the exact same
parameters from the original population
only here I intentionally did not allow
them to have interactions okay but I
didn't touch the LD in the population
and you can see we still observe this
this trend and so I was like ah man
bummer this is the and this is the
problem is this is a multicollinearity
problem right so the predictors are
correlated to each other
but we can ask are they greater than
expected by chance and so what I did was
I plotted those epistatic or interaction
effects from the the true data and this
you know the additive only simulated
data and if if there's no effect we
should not see any deviation from this
this diagonal line and I multiplied them
by the inner by they're additive effect
sign so that if they have a negative
relationship they should have a low tail
here and if they have a positive
relationship they should have a tail
here and you'll notice for heading date
we see this this push down that's
indicating that these are more negative
than expected by chance unless I see
some for plant heights down here but you
know we see it reflected not a lot for
grain yield and it's unclear for test
weight it doesn't look like a whole lot
of signal interestingly if I remove the
LD pattern in the population then I see
this this effect is to some extent
emphasized again I'll come back to that
in a minute
we also ah I'm gonna skip over this okay
so so we looked at okay so so not a lot
of large effect interactions but do they
increase prediction accuracy we see that
modeling all pairwise gives us this bump
from the ads right additive model all
pairwise interactions and the homie alla
ggest attak interactions explain between
you know 60 to 75 percent of of that
increase now this is a very small
increase so for sanity's sake we also
sampled pairs random pairs within and
across the genome
of markers and then we looked at their
prediction accuracy and you'll see that
we actually got higher prediction
accuracy with these random pairs across
which might be like oh man did we did we
you know did we miss something why would
we expect random pairs within a genome
or across the sub genomes to have higher
prediction accuracies than the
homologous I if anything I would expect
them to be about the same and the reason
I think is we see an a much higher rate
of linkage disequilibrium so here I'm
plotting the leakage disequilibrium
parameter D Prime so it's been
standardized and so the the solid line
here is the homologous set and then the
dotted lines are our two random sets and
you notice that there's an enrichment
for fixation at homeo allelic sites so
certain pairs of homeo alleles are being
fixed okay and this is this you so an
example of this would be the dorsum
genes just to bring it back
most modern wheat varieties have a
single dwarfing gene because they get
the reduced stature that helps them
resist lodging but if you have both
dwarfing genes you're too short and
you're not you're not economically
harvestable so so what we've done is we
fixed pairs right we fixed pairs where
you have a wild-type and a mutant and a
mutant and a wild-type and you never
have a double mutant or and it's rare to
have double wild okay so this this may
be this may explain why we're seeing
lower prediction errors
additionally physical position is not
necessarily a good indicator of LD right
you know it's both position and the time
of those of those mutations that
indicate lb and I'm not going to go into
this into too much detail but there's
also some difficulty in picking specific
sets of markers to call homie oolagah
right given that given that we don't
know we're just using physical position
to assign these as opposed to say
linkage disequilibrium now that would be
really difficult to do because it's not
just it's not just LD between the marker
and the functional polymorphism but also
LD between marker the functional
polymorphism on the other arm and their
interaction right so this it's not a
problem for simple gos right
tagging these and it's not a problem for
all pairwise interactions because you
test everything but here we're only
testing a very small subset of that okay
so really so we do see these
interactions tend to be less than
additive for some traits that appears
pretty clear homie allylic pairs pairs
explain some of this increase in genetic
predictability but not more so than
random pairs and this may be due to LD
or lo pairing so we need a better way to
pair markers and in my last five minutes
okay and so this this this paper is
essentially written it needs to be
tightened up a little bit and we're
waiting for wheat genome consortium to
publish their paper so that we can
publish and they've had the genome
available for quite some time now and
they won't let anyone publish on it
until they publish so anyway we're
waiting for that in the last few minutes
I'm gonna go into a strategy I use so I
had a problem tag right so there's this
question of am I having a hard time
tagging specific homeo alleles with
specific markers right they may not be
in high LD well what if we use more than
one pair right so with with with I
talked about the pairwise epistasis the
problem with this is a multiple test
problem you have 11,000 markers or so
you end up with you know 67 million
tests and a bonferroni correction is
really hard to see especially for
interactions which tend to only have
maximized variability at allele
frequencies of point 5 right so as those
a little frequencies go to 0 you reduce
the effect of the ability to see the
interaction and that variance gets
partitioned to additive variance but
what if we just looked at chromosome
arms what if we took individual
chromosome arms and looked at contrast
it to see if those arms were were
interacting with one another
this would drastically reduce the you
know now I'm only looking at 42
different chromosome arms we 861 total
test so the bonferroni correction is way
less okay so
you know again essentially what I did
was I took our model and it pulled out a
couple of chromosome arms and model
their interaction and then we do a
series of likelihood ratio tests to
determine if the additive effects or the
interaction or and the interaction is
significant and then mmm essentially we
can plot the p-values and here in light
gray is the additive p-value so is the
additive effect significant and in dark
gray is the interaction effect
significant you'll notice that that
essentially so so you know these are
these would be considered significant
over here these are not these are
essentially a p-value of one and so
you'll notice for these four traits most
of the at most of the chromosome arms
have an additive effect a significant
additive effect which makes sense that's
what we expect we expect large pieces of
chromatin to have effects on a phenotype
but you'll notice most of the
interactions are not which is good
because we don't expect all of these
things to be interacting with each other
necessarily and then of course when
these various parameters were estimated
on boundary you have a problem with
essentially but they end up being zero
so that's where you get this really this
big lump of key values instead of the
uniform the expected uniform
distribution okay and then I just want
to show so these are the results from a
bond for running correction what's
interesting is we see some sites where
it looks like we have you know four d
six a seven D big regulator or you know
some site that appears to be interacting
with many loci which is maybe suggestive
of some kind of gene regulator if we
relax this cut off a little bit and just
look at interactions that were
significant at say point zero zero one
just just to look at a pattern I'm not
saying that these are causing I'm just
curious we see that we see that this
this appears you know we see these these
sites where just a bunch of interactions
with a single locus or single chromosome
here's another one for heading day right
it's it looks like it's affecting a
bunch of different things and so we see
some of these hotspots you know on seven
seven D seven seven be here and for V or
excuse me for Dean
recently there was paper by young that
came out last year and they also saw
this enrichment at 7b and 7d so you know
or these are this is essentially the
same thought that there's this rotated
but they saw that these two chromosomes
appeared to have a lot of you know
appear to be influencing a lot of
regions they also saw an area on 4a
which we didn't see but we saw the 4d
seem to be important just looking at the
homologous chromosome arms we don't see
a whole lot of evidence for this this is
a bonferroni correction we only were to
consider all the ones they're
significant it's 8.05 or their
interactions we see this now you're
probably wondering what the colors are
the colors are due to are basically
colored the relationship between the
additive and the epistatic effect so if
they're blue there's a positive
relationship between the additive and
the epistatic effect and if they're red
there's a negative relationship and if
they're black there's you know or gray
there's no based on just a correlation
coefficient and what's one of them one
of the things i like to point out in my
last minute is that for the for BL and
for dl here has a had a really strong
negative and when we when we plotted
this you can see there's this drastic
negative relationship between the
additive effects early interaction so
this might indicate this might be
another indicator or some
functionalisation however when we looked
at this for a different trait right so
this was for plant this is for plant
height this is for testing there was we
did not see the same pattern and when we
looked at our spot where we assumed we
might see the interaction of the two
dwarfing genes we don't have a whole lot
of them from the bee genome in our
population but we don't really see much
of a pattern here although there is okay
so we see a lot of these interactions
granule handsome few potentially it
looks like we see some regions there
have large ret you know large regulatory
regions you can be interacting with many
different low huh and we see strong
relationships between some of these
homologous arm pairs in
hating that we may have some of these
homie Ollie you know that there may be
relationships between these homeo Leo's
additionally I think that I think that a
lot of this stuff probably is really
suggestive and probably needs a lot more
fine-tuning I think a lot more research
can be done I imagine I imagine that
there are some other populations that
you could look at this and as opposed to
a breeding population where you fix a
lot of these interactions you could look
at a synthetic wheat population which
would maximize these these interactions
and so I think that there is much more
research needed into into how these
three genomes are talking to each other
to produce a phenotype and so at my pag
talk was in translational genomics and
it was I gave some of this information
and I had to figure out how what the
translation was okay so my translation
is uh I will probably plays or not over
the last hundred years we have been
treating owl polyploid props as diploid
because they undergo disomic inheritance
right so you can treat them as diploid
because the chromosomes pair up and
segregate you know in a behaved manner
but we now have the molecular tools to
start to look at these things as the
immortal hybrids that they are and with
that I'd like to acknowledge my
committee members mark Searles
John Luke Yannick here mark couldn't be
here today he is at a he's at CIMMYT and
Jason easy some great folks in the yonex
Rose lab I worked closely with Lisa
kissing Cusack and Lynn bean straw on
some G by E stuff I've also gotten some
really good input from tars you
and you che and Martin and Roberto
Roberto I will point out was the first
person that said hey you know you could
go in and like look at those coding
sequences and then see if she could find
pairs and I was like oh yeah good idea
and then of course without the help of
the folks at the small grains David
venture Amy Fox and Justin Chavez and
James we're all here I couldn't have had
this data to ask these questions with
and so I very much appreciate their work
into this as well as the relationships
we developed over time yeah and thank
you guys very much
one last one I'm writing I'm keeping you
guys late I really like to thank my
family they've given me a lot of support
and I couldn't have finished this
without them and I would like to thank
particularly my father who is here today
and my girlfriend Amy who also joined us
today and thank you all Skyler ization
of the environment
thank you sort of a minus one to plus
two I said presented do you think that
as a as an asymmetry and that measures
that yeah that's a good question
so I centered all of this data so
theoretically so but what I did was I no
no no I can I can explain this
so what I didn't want to do was Center
the data so this is all standardized
data right you subtract mean and divide
by the standard deviation now I could
have centered within each environment
but I didn't want to do that because
then you are assuming that every
environment has the same bearings both
error and genetic variance okay so what
I did instead was I centered on
everything at the same time and so then
if if the environment size is for
example like right there might remember
which three
it was in was there it was a heavier on
the negative side or heavier on the
positive well I thought I'd seen there
was debris on the houses so that could
be from if there were larger trials that
tended to be better trials those ones
would push that whole that whole thing
right because you're taking a meat
so as you summarize that thing you're
you're you're you're taking a single
point for something that had maybe 400
genotypes in it that was a particularly
good environment and then another single
point that maybe only had 200 genotypes
that was particularly bad right so that
that's going to shift that that mean
point of the environmental I mean
roughly they should be close to centered
around zero but they weren't because I
think because I Center the data as in as
a whole as opposed to within environment
how to done it with an environment they
should evolve then smack down a zero the
opportunity cost duplication is a much
more conservative process than full
genome colonization and yeah if the
hypothesis is true which is that every
basically every interest burden is
undergone at least one mile maybe two or
three of whole genome we gain and loss
right my question is do you see the kind
of preferential loss Oh mostly in these
more you know he's replete polyploid
that we see in the long term perspective
on all of our nation that they actually
get
made up more than half the genes but
they don't want to bother to maintain
either because of your Chum
they are fortunately done or maybe
there's a cost to the new
functionalities and you expect to see
complete loss and how much loss you see
even death we G right okay so to repeat
the question essentially the idea is in
diploid species you have genes that get
duplicated and then and then those are
oftentimes subsequently lost because
they're unnecessary right right and so
and during a whole genome duplication
yeah and that happens and then do we see
that same thing happen now the answer is
yes in fact it happens really
drastically especially very shortly
after the hybridization event they
usually go through this this weird G I
mean this genome shock moment where
they're like oh my god well how am I
gonna deal with all of this right and so
oftentimes big big chunks break cuz
you're gonna have a lot of negative
epistasis too so there's this other
thing that happens where you can think
of a gene from this species and a gene
from that species while they work
completely fine within their own species
you bring them together and all of a
sudden like think of like a homeo dimer
for example i think this is a good
example the homeo dimer is formed from
the product of protein products within
the two species are functional but you
might have a thing where they can still
bind together and form a heterodimer
across these two really closely related
genes that may disrupt their function so
I think that when that kind of thing
happens there is a there is a push to
get you know to Wow
I don't know about a push but there is a
selective advantage to drop a lot of
these really important and we do see
that in fact so of the you know a
hundred and ten thousand or so genes in
the genome I was only able to get
triplicates for like
so 110,000 genome you divide that by
three of roughly looking at a haploid
number of 33,000 genes okay I was only
able to get 18 of them that had at least
three copies or no was it at least two
copies yeah at least two cop no I have
to go look at it okay yeah so there's
you know a third of the genome has been
lost and there was a bunch of
Singleton's the other thing that happens
is you get a lot of tandem duplications
and that's 210 duplications are super
interesting because they have a tendency
to be Co inherited whereas duplications
across chromosomes there's no there's no
linkage that holds them together yeah I
think most diverse team writes more so
so there's a spot that essentially on
the old functionalisation goes through a
process of sub functionalisation where
at first they start off the exact same
function and then you have small
mutations that change them a little bit
and then eventually they develop such
different pieces and I think that this
is really evident when you look at genes
genes have these domains right and it's
interesting that you can stick these
domains together and have this thing
that you know so you can like it's
almost like mix and match you know what
do they put this poison yeah they're
like Legos yeah yeah and so yeah I think
it's really important and that I I would
be I would be super curious to try this
in a species that is kind of in-between
that whole genome duplication event and
being an already becoming a diploid and
seeing if we could find evidence of this
happening in you know across
non-homologous site that really
yeah they lost more let's say do you see
more losses right when you bring I think
you also bring a thing in there's
probably a lot of stuff that's good but
most of it actually so there is I would
assume that much I should tabulate that
I should see how many the ones I saw you
know where the third copy that I didn't
have was from the DG I wouldn't be
surprised this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu